من الدوحه الى مسقط تنوعت المدن والهدف
واحد
تمتين محبي العلوم من متابعه رحله الم
بعين للحصول على اللقب الاخرى مخترع العرب
لحظات ويبدا حصل تخرج الجيل التاسع من
نجوم العلوم
ام
[موسيقى]
نعم
ام
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته حياكم
الله متابعين الكرام عبر التلفزيون وايضا
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
انه نهائي الموسم التاسع من جميع العلوم
برنامج العلم مؤكد 100 الابتكار الذي
اطلقته مؤسسه قطر للتربيه والعلوم وتنميه
المجتمع يكون حاضرا للشباب العربي المبدع
وليحرر قادر افهم في اطار منافسه علميه هي
الاولى من نوعها اربعه وتسعين نواجه
تحديات علميه صعب ليصل الى هذه النهائيات
وعلى مدى اسبوع كامل صوت نشاط العلوم
للمبتكر المفضل لديهم وبقي تصويت لجنه
التحكيم المركزي عمان للمؤتمرات والمعارض
تنطلق بعد لحظات نهائيات الموسم لحظات
يعيش فيها الاربعه حفل تخرجهم معاذ ام لا
هل ومحبي العلوم
على مشارف العاصمه في خليج مسقط حضر محبوا
العلوم لدعم المبدعين الاربعه قبيل
التصويت النهائي
عمان اليوم نهائي نجوم العلوم الموسم
التاسع موجود هنا في مصر اهلا وسهلا
لما يشوف الشباب والزمان اه معها ونسمع
القصص ما تخيلنا
عشر سنوات اليوم من عمر البرنامج
خمسه الشباب يكونوا رايحين اول شيء اكيد
الواحد بدو ابن البلد ويوصل بس كمان
الاختراع هو الاساس الله يكون بعون
المشركين يعني موقف يحسد عليه لا يحسد
عليه
من اول
هذه اللحظه احساسي احساس طالب مجتهد في
سنه كامله واليوم النتيجه النهائيه
انا جدا متفائل انه هذا المنتج راح ينزل
يوم من الايام في مكه المكرمه وراح يخدم
الحجاج
[تصفيق]
البحث او مربحه انا بيني وبين حالي مقتنع
باللي
كل شكرا لك النجوم كانت تتابع هم من سنوات
افهم والفين
بدنا بعد المرحله هذه اللي انت وصلت لها
كل الكويت
وان تواصل
احنا شعور واشراك
هي بدايه المشروع
بيكفي يطلعوا العالميه
الشباب
لك التوفيق ان شاء الله نشوف مجتمع عربي
جديد يضاف الى السماء التكنولوجيا الى
الوطن العربي
الحلقه النهائيه تستقبل جمهورا واسعا يضم
مسؤولين وكبار الشخصيات العربيه جاء من
بلادهم خصيصا لدعم العلوم والمبدعين
لجنه التحكيم جائزه لقول كلمتها الاخيره
التنفس فؤاد مراه الدكتور عبد الحميد
الزهيري والدكتور خالد العالي وحث نهايه
نجوم العلوم لا يكتمل من دون
خالد الجمهوريين اهلا بكم مجددا في هذه
الليله المصيريه جهاز بقيمه ستمائه الف
دولار امريكي ولا قد نجوم العلوم وللمره
الاولى وبفضل التعاون الواعد بين مؤسسه
قطر والصندوق العماني للتكنولوجيا سيعلن
اسم الفائز من سلطنه عمان بعد رحله علميه
استماره اسابيع س يلمع في سماء نجم جديد
احمد محمد
اليوم نهايه الموسم التاسع الذي عاش فيه
المشتركون لحظات لا تنسى
هذا التقرير استرجع اجواء الموسم التاسع
من نجوم العلوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صغيره زرعت
فاصبحت شجره وارفه تحمل اختراعات عالميه
غير مفهوم الابداع بالاختراعات البديل
اخرى تواكب التطور التكنولوجي السريع في
العالم اليوم
الطبيب و عيادته واستاذ الجامعه
والمهندس مكتبه والطالب الدكتور اه كتب
الكل يحلم بنزول
هدف رئيسي
تراجع من على من العرب ابتكارات خريجي
دخلت الاسواق من الصين الى الولايات
المتحده
ومن العالم العربي الى اوروبا
اليوم وبعد تسع مغامرات يخرج البرنامج
مبدعين اربعه ابتكارات يفتخر بها العرب
ومؤسسه قطر للتربيه والعلوم وتنميه
المجتمع
مشوار الموسم التاسع بدا بعمليه بحث دقيقه
موسم شرحت مشاريعه لجنه تحكيم ثابته ضمت
البروفيسور المراد والدكتور عبد الحميد
السعودي والدكتور خالد العالم
تجار عديده ومشاريع بديهيه
حاسس حاله صغيرات العلوم
الاقتراح
اثنين بسرعه
بالمقابل
اخرى في ابداعها العلمي في الواقع هيك انا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وحقيقه للعلوم والتكنولوجيا زرعت ابوابها
لتسعه مبتكرين
في لزوم العلوم خبرا مبتكرون الجدد صعوبات
من نوع جديد
هايدا مش كبيره الطويل
بال بال عاش وتحديات السباق مع الزمن
والتنافس العلمي
هيدا مش كثير
كل ابتكار يحمل مشاكل لا حصر لها
الطريق
وكل مشكله تشكل عائقا امام تنفيذ المشاريع
حاولت تعقد الامور
وانتخبت عقيده
اطباء ومهندسون و خبراء عالميون درسوا
معارفهم لمساعدتهم
[موسيقى]
ضغوطات نفسيه الهائل
تركوا الاهل والاصدقاء بمغامره عليه
ووصلوا في نهايتها الى تنفيذ تسعه منتجات
فعاله
[موسيقى]
الليله يكتمل العدد المتاهلين الاقبال
اغنى يعرض تطبيع احرقت 5 ابتكارات
لتكتمل الصوره النهائيه
لانهاء الموسم
ام
مشعل يشهد الحياه عند اتمام مناسك الحج مع
سوار الملاحه للحجاج ان احاطت بدراسه
امريكا خطرت المشروع مع شركه ناسا للفضاء
علشان جدا فكره للشعب العربي اخبار الدار
ووصلتنا الان
يحدث ثوره في عالم من ان فعاله الغزل
الكهربائي العازل ما
هذا الشي اللي اذا اقول م شويه كان شخص
محبط مثل تسعين بالمائه من الشباب العربي
كان شاب عايش اجواء الفشل كل يوم ايضا
الشيء اللي وصلنا محمد
يتطلعوا الى خدمه اطفال العالم مع التعليم
ال ال التفاعلي للاطفال الصوم مع الاراده
لا يوجد مستحيل وانما من الناس مكان منهم
فكرتك بتسوى الشيء الوحيد اللي يمنع الفكر
ان تشوف النور
احمد يفتح باب عمليات جراحيه الامنه مع
مؤشر افتراضي لمنظار جراحي
تلقائيه الهجوم العلوم بمجرد فكره وهذه
الفتره خمسه واربعين يوم فقط تحولت لواقع
وهي الواقع
جدا في الوصول امنها
الليله
واحد منهم سيتربع على عرش العلوم العربيه
البينه سليل الابداع العربي سماء العلوم
الان ابدا مرحله جديده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بعد اللجنه التحقيق دكتور فؤاد
المراد نعود معك الى الماضيه رافقت برنامج
نجوم العلوم من تسع سنوات هل ترى يعني
تحسن في مستوى الابتكارات والمشاريع اللي
شاركوا فيها شباب العالم العربي بشكل عام
والى اي مدى هذا التغير
تذكر لي انه
يعني
اللي بدي اقول لك انه اذا بتحكي في الشباب
الموجودين معنا يعني انا اذا سمح الله
واحد بالعالم بالعالم مش بس العام العربي
شو هي التكنولوجيات الواحد الخمسين سنه
اللي قدام بيقولوا لك ان والتكنولوجي
والتي ويربط يعني ممثلين معنا
التكنولوجيات الوحده والناشئه للعالم كله
هذا هو برنامجهم العلوم يواكب التسارع في
العالم والتكنولوجيات
يعني
شديد معهم ان اسال انه بدي اتاكد انه هيك
نوويه هي الوقت واحده وهي اللي عم فرجينا
لبنان واصل العالم بصراحه تقول كيفيه
شكرا دكتور فؤاد المراه الكلام عن الماضي
ليس حنين ابل تجارب وانجازات حققها خريجو
نجوم العلوم فاصبحوا مثالا للشباب العربي
ومن هم نجم العلوم للموسم الثاني الكويتي
صادق قاسم اين هو صادق اليوم
[تصفيق]
مشوار النجاح ما يكون وليد اللحظه هي
خطوات
فيها وفشل لحد ماتوصل للمرحله اللي انت
تنفي
مشاركتهم في نزول العلوم تغيرت مسار حياته
[موسيقى]
التجاره البيئي بالمركز الاول مع هذا صادق
الى موطنه الكويت اثرا حياتهم للاختراع
والابداع
اكبر الاجتماعات حكي الى انها هو اول
اختراق لضغط اني اعطي على ارض الواقع بشكل
احترافي من هذا الاختراع انا تعلمت
المعايير بناء اي نموذج صناعه
اليوم رصيد صادق حافل بالاختراعات
والجوائز
حاليا لديه سوى سته اختراعات من واجب
صناعيه
هذا الاختراق هو اخر في الحقيقه تشتغل
عليه يعني تصنع من الصين عشره الاف
واحتلوا ال خلال الايام بتامل انه هو
يكتسح السوق الخليجي انه وروح لحل معضله
ومشكله من زمان انها ستعاني
صادق الان خطوه بالشباب الكويتي ينير
طريقهم ويعطيهم مفاتيح الابتكار العالم
وايدك النقاش ان تتحسن حق النموذج لصناعه
الجواب في الشغل عندكم هذا غلط
ال بطبيعه الحال عنده اهداف في حياتي وانا
حققت اغلب الاهداف لابيها لكن ما يمنع ان
تتاسس جيل ثاني يكون بمستوى اللي انتو
صوته احسن منه
[موسيقى]
ولا احمد
اتمنى ان بعد فتره من الزمن والدي يشوف
يشوف الجوائز يشوف الانجازات اللي حققتها
الحبيبه
وان شاء الله كل المشاركين العلوم ان شاء
الله ولد احمد اصلاحات منها اليوم يستقبل
نجوم العلوم العديد من المسؤولين وكبار
الشخصيات حضروا لدعم البرنامج والعلوم
بشكل عام منهم ضيف مميز المهندس يوسف
الحارثي الرئيس التنفيذي للصندوق العماني
للتكنولوجيا الذي وقع مؤخرا مذكره تفاهم و
عام مؤسسه قطر للتربيه والعلوم وتنميه
المجتمع
اه في البدايه طبعا نشكر لكم حسن الضيافه
في سلطنه عمان اشيء المجالات اللي ستعملون
مع مؤسسه قطر فيها
اتفاقياتنا مع مؤسسات قطر هي من ثلاث
جوانب الجانب الاول والاهم هو بناء اه
بيئه استثماريه جاذبه العقول و جاذبه
للاستثمارات مولده للابتكارات من المنطقه
و استغلال الطاقات البشريه الكبيره
الكامنه في الشباب العربي واعدامهم الفرصه
نحن نعمل مع بعض ان شاء الله بس تر النور
في الفين وفي منطقه الشرق في هذا الجانب
كذلك في موضوع التدريب ونقل التكنولوجيا
وسائل فعاله في هذا الجانب ال الخطوه
الثالثه اللي هي الاستثمار المشترك على ما
تم الاستثمار عليه في كلا الجانبين
احنا نجي نكمل على الجهد الخير
بدات فيه واحد عليه اكمل بعض دائما شكرا
اه المهندس يوسف الحرب الرئيس التنفيذي
للصندوق العماني اللي
حلقه الليله تتارجح بين الماضي والحاضر
بين نجاحات الخريجين السابقين
والمتنافسين النهائيين الاربعه في القصير
تتواصل فيه معكم عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لجنه التحكيم دور اساسي في البرنامج من
تصفيات المشاركين الاولى وحتى اختيار
الفائز لهذا الموسم يشارك للمره الاولى
الدكتور خالد العالي الدكتور حياك الله
الله يحييك
بصراحه ساعات ضحيه الصراع اللي قاعد يصير
بين دكتور فؤاد المراد والدكتور زهير اللي
تحسن نفس ال حصلنا ولا غير صحيح
الجديد نقول ال اللي بينهم هذه بالنسبه لي
انا قاعد رقبه من بعيد تشوف
هذا اللي
بيكون الفاصل بين الحاميه الوطيس ان هناك
وكان تواصل خير بين وان شاء الله طيب كيف
عشره التجربه العلميه الجديده هذه مع
المبدعين اللي اليوم وان شاء الله يعني
الجماعه اللي معي هنا انا فخوره كون معهم
انه نشوف شباب مثل هذا الشباب نقول احنا
كعرب فينا الخير واحيانا روح الابتكار
اللي احنا معروفين عندنا من على فكره
جزيلا لك
طبع في الموسم الثاني بحيويتها وكل
المتابعين يتذكرون حركات الرياضيه العفويه
خلال التصفيات بشوشه و نشطه ومثابره و
متفوقه بشكل عام في شتى مراحل البرنامج
حقيقه لهذا الفريق
منذ سبع سنوات من هنا بدات قصه نجاحها
[موسيقى]
لبنان
اتجاه هذا غير مسار حياتها
واليوم
مركز التكنولوجيا في العالم تعمل على
تطوير
الى نظارات السباحه
دقات القلب والسيارات الحراريه المعروفه
وال اشواط التي قطعها السباح وقتها بلشت
كانت اكثر مقتنعه عم يشتري ال بايدي بدانا
استعملوا
اللي عم بيشتغلوا بايديهم وانا عم انه
نحنا وين راح نعمل
اليوم صارت شركه بين لبنان وامريكا ونعمل
كل الصناعه بالصين بالاربعه وعشرين ساعه
في محل بالعالم عم بيشتغل على ان تثبيته
عم بيحضر شغل الفريق الثاني بينما حل ولكل
الانتخابيه اللي طورنا هم باخر 7 سنين هذا
اول واحد
من جنوب لبنان
راح تصير بالسوق
الحلم يبلش فكره على ورقه اليوم
صار عندي
بس بعد فيه كثير بدنا نعملها وفي الحجم
الاكثر اللي هو انه غير كيف السباحين عم
بيسمح
القطريه طموح دخل مجال الابداع العلمي
بحثا عن حل للمشاكل يعيشها مجتمعنا العربي
لديه اهتمامات كثيره بدات في كتابه قصص
الاطفال لنتعرف سويا الى شخصيه من يحاول
كتابه قصه الشخصيه في نجوم العلوم محمد
الجفيري
جاء من قطر حامل حكايات الطفوله واحلامها
جمع محمد الجفيري بين حبه للمجتمع هو
التطور التكنولوجي
[موسيقى]
كان يا ما كان في قديم الزوار احلى جمل
كانت اسماءها قبل ان ام
في
القصص كانت خلينا نفكر القصص ليه يعني
نهايتها مفتوحه اخر قبل واحلام كلها يعني
مثل السحر كانت المساله
احساس
عرفنا ان كبرنا خلاص
بينما تكون لنا ايه قصص لكن اه او يكتب
قصص واقعيه القصص اللي كتبها علي
الرئيس لما محمد ولد انا احساسي اصبح تلجا
المسؤول وان هذا الطفل لازم يجعل الانسان
جاد مثل ايام لازم تستمر الى الابد طلب
العلم وتوجه عمير به وليس في الكتابه في
روايته الخاصه للاطفال دراسته اخذته الى
عدم الكبار متخصص في تدريب القاده وتخرج
من اي بي سي باريس يعطيكم العافيه جميعا
على تواجدكم اليوم ان شاء الله راح نتكلم
عن القياده الموقفيه
تدرب الشباب في مجال اعداد القاده
ومن هنا برنامج تدريبي اسم اعداد قاده من
ذوي الاعاقه و من الحضور كان في فئه خاصه
لفئات الصنف فشلت اني اوصل لهم المعلومات
اللي
اكتشفت انه مستوى الفهم للمصطلحات انت
الصم اقل بكثير من الشخص العادي
فقررت اني انا ضخم وحل جذورها المشكله
اهلا
[موسيقى]
احنا بين جدا التواصل و للتعامل مع اول ام
الصنف ما نوصل المعلومه او الدرس
لغه الاشاره صعبه جدا معلمه واقل حركه
بتغير م عن خالص
وخبرته الداخليه اعادته الى الطفوله ليكتب
في الستم جديده
[موسيقى]
بتذكر محمد
لتعليم الاطفال السوق لغه الاشاره العربيه
يروى في قصص كتبها محمد ويتواصل مره
باسلوب تفاعلي بانتظار
انا صرت وهو الحين وعندي بنتين اللي كان
بناتنا يسلمون وبعضهم كيف يشوفون الخيار
لان ابكر هذا الخيار ال اذا شافوه راح
يتحول الواقع
[موسيقى]
انا لك التوفيق ان شاء الله محمد انت بقيه
المشاركين معك في هذا الموسم خرج من
الموسم الخامس وساده خاليه ولم يستسلم من
خبره علميه اكتسبها في نجوم العلوم دابر
في عمله و حقق ما اراد في وساده ذكيه لمن
يعاني من مشاكل في السمع
حياك الله
تمام محمد الجفيري مثلك يعني يهتم في
مشاكل متعلقه
بالسمع مشابه الى حد كبير مع وسادتك اللي
شارك فيها في الموسم الخامس ما رايك واللي
انا واخي محمد شفافيه نفس السوق السوري
عندهم مشاكل سمعيه وتواجه تحديات كثير
ضخمه واختراع اخي محمد يساهم لبناء اجيال
نتعلم كثير وهذا الاقتراع اللي هو طالع
فيه حل تحديات كثير كبيره هلا موجوده
بالسوق طيب اه رايك توقعاتك حظوظه في
القاهره
اخي محمد الجفيري بصراحه في موقف لا يحسد
عليه ليش لانه مشاريع جباره جدا منافسه
قويه كثير هو يستحق والله بالك لمستقبل
انا بتمنى للتوفيق والنجاح هو اكيد حتى لو
ما كان من المراتب الاولى هو اكيد ضحيه
يكمل بمشروعه ونواصل شكرا لك شكرا
مثل انوار محمد اهتم بمن يعاني من مشاكل
في السمع فكان ابتكار وسيله لتعليم لغه
الاشاره للاطفال الصمت
بهذا التقرير
تعلم لغه الاشاره
امر معقد و ممل بالنسبه
لالاف الاطفال السوق
هو ربو تفاعلي لتسهيل عمليه تعليم الاطفال
السوق
يتعرف
الى الاشارات اليدويه عبر كاميرا و برنامج
متخصص بتحليل لغه الاشاره العربيه
يستخدم الربط يدا اليه وشاشه عرض للتواصل
مع الطفل بطريقه مسليه وقع هذا
باسلوب تفاعلي سال وممتعه يصحح الروبوت
زيد الاخطاء او يكافئ الاداء الصحيح للطفل
[موسيقى]
تعلم لغه الاشاره اسهل
وتواصل بدون ما
[تصفيق]
التقرير الصور بناتي العنود والهنوف
انا بشتغل ها اللحظه واقول لهم
اليوم كل عام وانت بخير اليوم يوم ميلادك
لكن انا قاعد احاول اقدم شيء للبشريه
من احسن من ان شاء الله بتكون ها المشوار
تكون نجوم العلوم واستمر المسيره ان شاء
الله ويتبعون بعد دكتور فؤاد
احب شكرا لكم
احب يستغل ها الفرصه اشكر سلطنه عمان
واقول لهم ايضا اه مبروكين على اليوم
الوطني وايضا اشكر مؤسسه قطر على اتاحتها
الفرصه الذهبيه هذه انها طلعت مشروع هذا
الى النور وسلط الضوء على فئه مهمه جدا في
المجتمع
ضعاف السمع والصلب واتمنى باذن الله اليوم
انه حصل كل دعم كل هذا المشروع حتى يحصل
على المراكز الاولى باذن الله ويقدم هذا
المشروع خدمه
واثق الخطوه يمشي ملك واثق بقدراته واثق
باصراره واثق بان العمل الدؤوب سيقوده الى
نجاح يعيش معظم وقته متنقلا بين المختبر
والمختبر لا تعرف جويا الى اللبناني فؤاد
مقصود
مشرف واد مقصود في محيط يدعو الى الهدوء
والشاعر تفضل صاحب العلوم وتحتها
احيانا يكون الاختراع وليد الصدفه وغالبا
ما يبدا في سن الطفوله
عند
كانت ركنيه تعلم من كيسي
يجيب علامات الاول بصفه واعطوا اللي يجي
اللي ابابا تنظيم يهمني العالميه
اللي بالعلامات
[موسيقى]
عندما يكبرون زال ولا
للنظر
من سبعطاشر سنه من قبل
[موسيقى]
اما محمد هي بمثابه
وانابيب بيتها مثل ما بعت بيتي ان شاء
الله يا رب
ايضا البيت تعلمت منه دروس ما بين سياق
الحياه
نحنا من احد السياره بالالفين السياره
فيما
توفي
[موسيقى]
لنفس السبب
تخصص في الجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت في
مجال الهندسه الكيميائيه وان وتكنولوجيا
بان حصان الجامعه الامريكيه ببيروت
لما لا
قادر تقدم شيء المجال الطبي كان اول خيار
جدا جدا
يعني احنا كنا
نعرف ان تشتغل تشتغل فؤاد السيد في زمان
ها التكنولوجي باريس
يوصلها التكنولوجيا
العمل المستمر في الجامعه لم يكن كافيا
اراد نتائج ملموسه وسريع تبني مختبره
الخاص في بيت الى ال اتصل برئيس
مرات الاميل نحو الف من برا
بس هذا كله من خلال موسم واحد بس
تحقق حلم فئات في نجوم العلوم لان سكن
تستخدم ال ال فوهه مع تكنولوجيا النانو
لتغيير القماش فيصبح معالج طبيا للخروق
والتقرحات الجلديه او عازمه بالمياه
[موسيقى]
نعم
مستقبلا على ونحنا من الجامعه الامريكيه
اخرى انت عملت لنا
[تصفيق]
راح يبيض الوجه ان شاء الله وكل 4 اللى
معاه وكل زملائي بيضون وجه باذن الله حين
ينتقل بيت العلوم الى سلطنه عمان فمن
الطبيعي ان يكون سلطان الصبحي من الحاضرين
في هجوم العلوم هو بيته احنا عندنا في بيت
الله بالنور العماني
المكان واهل البيت احنا بيوت الله
شكرا الرياض سلطان
اه
والتجاره
الكيميائي
وانا من متابعتي اه خلال مراحل البرنامج
فؤاد يعني امكان بروح مثابره عاليه
يعني ب بدون مبالغه تفوق الباقي المشترك
حظوظه
على المركز الاول
[تصفيق]
الابتكار يحتاج الى الوقت ولكثير من الجهد
ليشكل طفره نوعيه في التكنولوجيا يمكن
استخدامها لتحسين حياه الانسان وايضا في
علاجه هذا ما اراده فؤاد من ابتكار نانس
كان
ما نسكر هذه صناعيه تستخدم تكنولوجيا
او الجزيئات المتناهيه في الصغر
لتغيير القماش فيصبح عازلا للمياه او
معالجه طبيه مع الحفاظ على ت نفسه ومكانته
بالجهاز على اكثر من الف تسريب المواد
الكيماويه
مستخدما قوه حقل كهربائي على التنافر تنشر
الثياب على قاعده متحركه داخل غرفه الجهاز
ليغسل جزيئات النانو كهربائي بماده عازله
او سواء عبر فوهات شهريه ف تصبح ثياب
عازله للماء او بماده للحروق والجروح دون
سبب مصابات الهواء
يقوم القماش المعالج بايصال الدواء بكميه
مناسبه ولمده مدروسه وفي موضوع محدد
لمعالجه الحروق
والتقرحات الجلديه
والتشنجات العضليه
امس كان قد ما جدوى بالثياب
بيني يخلص المشوار الاكاديميه نجوم العلوم
مدرسه تعلمت من كثير درجه ماني قادر
اتركها الا كخطوه اولى المسيره نانس كل
اللى يعرفنى عم بيقول فؤاد ما راح يقبل
الليله الاول على جميع تمارين مثل ما كان
عم بيصير بكل المراحل السابقه
صح
الهدف الاول اثر بكل شباب وصبايا في
عالمنا العربي لا ينسى
طموح هيدي المره مش من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولا حتى من قلب عالمنا العربي
مبادره مؤسسه قطر ابتكار
جمع الهندسه في تكنولوجيا جديده اشبه
نموذج اثبت فعاليته بسحب تكنولوجيا الان
وبرات المختبر المدونات الحقوق البالغه
الس ليلى
هو الاساس ان حول ان سكان لواء طب متطور
لكن العالم
هنالك ان شاء الله كل التوفيق يا اخوان
الابداع العلمي هو اكثر ما يميز نهائي
الليله الموسم العاشر على الابواب من لديه
افكار ابداعيه بالتسجيل عن طريق الموقع
الالكتروني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نعم
اهلا بكم مجددا في الحلقه النهائيه من
الموسم التاسع من نجوم العلوم خلال هذا
الموسم كانت تنافس حاد بين الطب والهندسه
مصادر موثوقه تقول الى التطبيقات الخاصه
بالمجال الطبي كثيره في الموسم العاشر
يعني معارك طاحنه على الابواب لكن اكيد
دكتور زهير رايك في مستوى الابتكار دكتور
كان مستواها على وكان فيه نفسها قويه جدا
المنافسه انتقلت من المبتدئين ل لجنه
التحكيم كمان بس المتسابقين اه ولكن انا
بشوف انه الخلاف في الراي لا يفسد للود
القضيه والحقيقه انا اتفق مع الدكتور فؤاد
انه بعض الناس بتهمه انه هو شديد شويه بس
انا بشوف انه ناس بتيجي عندهم فكره غير
قابله للتنفيذ وغير مدروسه
انهم يبقى الواحد شديد معها
لا لا ما عندنا مشترك الموسم العاشره الله
يعينك انا دائما اؤمن انه ال الفكره
يعني الفكره هي واحد في المائه الايحاء
تسعه وتسعين في المائه عرب والمتابعه
ذكرى زياره
الشيخ خالد حفظ لقب الموسم الرابع و
اختراع عباره عن اداه
تخلط بصوره اليه مكونات الوجبه كما تقوم
بتخزين طريقه اعدادها اين هو قطريه خالد
سهم الان بعد مرور خمس سنوات على فوزه
رياضه الاعمال دائما تبدا الحلم مشكوك في
امره لكن في العزيمه والاصرار راح يتحول
الحلم الى حقيقه من الدوحه و من مختبري
نجوم العلوم كانت انطلاقه القطري
الان في الداخل جاهز لكن
الرابع
[موسيقى]
في العاصمه الكنديه
يكمل خالد اليوم كتابه مستقبله
كل اصدقائي في المدينه اللي درس فيها
وتعالى شبعه مش راكب من شركه نطور فيها هي
ونواصل ايدي الناس وينزل كمان
احنا قاعدين نحاول ان نقدم التجربه جديده
بالطبخ في البيت راح يتعزز من نمط الحياه
الصحي في ظل وثيره الحياه السريعه للعشرين
الى قلب يقوم القطر هي الوجبات
يساعد على مراقبه التاريخ الغذائي و
يسجلوا عدد السعرات الحراريه لكل وجبه
العالم كلها مهتم بالمطبخ الذكي والاكل
الصحي منا ميزان الى بلوغ احنا بدينا فيها
من الفين وعشر اليوم ان شاء الله راح
يقتنص كل هذه الفرص يحقق مستقبل نوعي
مظاهر في مجال الاكل الذكي والصحي باذن
الله
[موسيقى]
منطقه غرف العمليات ادواته تعني بالانسان
عمله الحفاظ على صحتنا وراحتنا حلم بالطب
صغيرا و في تطوير المعدات الجراحيه كبيره
اكيد
احمد نبيل من الكويت
ها هي الكويت تتالق مجددا في نهائيات
الهجوم العلوم ارسلت من ابنائها طبيبا
يخدم الانسانيه بابتكار طبي جديد
احمد او راح يكون دكتور لو صغير
العام
كلانا بها
هذا الميكرسكوب احتفظ في واحد وعشرين سنه
هذا ايدي
لما اشوف
وحتى تحت الميكرسكوب
واحد انا حاولت
طبعا خلال طفل يعني ولكنها كانت بدايه من
هناك
احمد كان من الطلبه المتميزين جدا المعلم
دائما الطالب المتميز يترك عنده انطباع ما
كان في النهائي يقتنع
بالحل التقليد اكثر ملاحظه كان يقولونها
المدرسين
انا
اسمع من الزملاء المعلمين ان احمد ما شاء
الله عليهم تفوق دائما
حقق احمد بين حلم الطفوله تدرس البشريه
وجراحه العامه وبدا حياته العمليه في هذا
المجال الطبي بالممارسه احمد نبيل في
المستشفى وان شاء الله عليه البيت الثاني
ابتسام دائما من خارجها وانا
على الطريق في هذا المستشفى اللي هو
مستشفى الاميري في غرفه العمليات تشارك
مشكله يعاني منها الجراحين احنا راح يواجه
صعوبات في عمليات المناطق الجراحيه لما
يكون مضيفه
وبالتالي وقت في تنظيف الممبار بدا
التركيز على العمليه نفسها انا شفت اجواء
غرفه العمليات وعشتها يعني ثلاثه من وجد
حل يخلي رؤيه واضحه قبل مده العمليه
في نجوم العلوم طور احمد نبيد المنظار
الجراحي
ينظر تلقائيا لتكون العمليات الجراحيه
اكثر دقه وسرعه وامان
[موسيقى]
البيئه لها دور كبير تكوين الانسان مستحيل
ان اكون وصلت وصلت بدون
يكون دعموني من البدايه
[موسيقى]
اليوم اللي اشوفك في دكتور عالمي باذن
الله تعالى
يعني خال احمد ولكن احمد ولد الدخول واحمد
صديقي منا للنجاح تكون في بدايه انطلاق
يعني حقيقيه
هذا الولد الصالح كل انسان
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله يعني
الله يوسف احمد ان شاء الله جميع اخوانه
امر حامد بدا مخترع في الموسم السابع مع
ابتكار
الكرسي الخاص بمساعده المصلين واصبح رجل
اعمال بعد تاسيسه لشركه الفا تصميم و
تسويق العلامات التجاريه من الهندسه الى
مجال الاعمال بشكل عام لا تتوقع ان اليوم
ايضا احمد راح ينتقل في مجال الطب الى
مجال اه الاعمال يعني سيد
احمد المنشاه الله فيه اذا اه
بضيفنا الدكتور
طرح ما ندري اذا كان احمد سيترك طب ما
نعرفها ان منظار سيشكل نقله كبيره في مجال
الجراحه تقرير بتعرفيه سويا على
[تصفيق]
هو تعديل على المنظار الجراحي ل يقوم
بتنظيف العدسه تلقائيا
يحتوي الغطاء الامامي لعدسه المطار على
قنوات صغيره
سهيل معظم يصف العدس ثم يشطف السائل عبر
قنوات اخرى تقابل قنوات الضخم الى خارج
الجسم دون الحاجه
في العمليه كما هو الحال مع ال من غير
التقليديه
تجري عمليه الدخل والشد
محسوبه لقوه الضغط وسرعه التدفق ودرجه
الحراره يزود التعديل المنظار ب مؤشر قوي
افتراضي يحدد بدقه منطقه اهتمام الجراحي
يساعدهم على تنسيق المهام فيما بينهم
اثناء العمليه كما يساهم المؤشر في نفسه
لتدريب الجناحين
يمكن اضافه اكثر من مؤشر والتحكم بها عبر
لوحه خاصه او عبر الهاتف النقال او
الكمبيوتر
ضفه طبيه جديده
لتكون العمليات الجراحيه اكثر دقه وسرعه
وامانه
وابتكار سيخدم الاطفال الطب وغيرهم من
الاطفال سيتم الحجاج وغيرهم من المسلمين
سيخدم العلماء وغيرهم من المبتكرين
قد يكون لوالده ووالدته او لطفله الموت
والحياه في غرف العمليات تفصلهم اشاره
واحده اذا في قلب ينبض بالحب وعقله بتفكر
بالتكنولوجيا ابتكرت اكسبو وبمساعده مؤسسه
خطا وبرنامج نجوم العلوم استطعنا تنفيذ
هذا الابتكار الذي سيساهم بشكل مباشر في
انقاذ الاربعه نحن اليوم اثبتنا للعالم
اننا لسنا مجرد امه تتغنى بماضي ابائها
واجدادها بل وقفنا جميعنا كلنا وقفنا صرخه
واحده ل نقول للعالم
اليوم التوفيق من الله قلت في بدايه
ببرنامج نجوم العلوم
انا على يقين انكم حضارات اعضاء لجنه
التحكيم على علم وحكمه وبعد نظر بما يكفي
لان تكتب نهايتها
[تصفيق]
كل التوفيق الاحمد ان شاء الله الابداع
يحاول في اغلب الاحيان ايجاد حلول علميه
الاحتياجات مجتمعنا العربي هذا ما قام به
مشعل مستفيدا من تجربته حين كان شابا من
هو المبدع السعودي مشعل الشهراني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا
قصيره في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
هذا القريه كانت يعني جدا متواضع من ناحيه
الخدمات من ناحيه التعليق
وادى ابو مشعل المثل الاعلى
في القبيله عندنا ما يخلي اي شيء يكون
عقبه ابناء التسعه كوني انا اكبر في
العائله عليها كثير مسؤوليات وقت ما تخرجت
من الثانويه وتوظفت شركه ارامكو السعوديه
اشتغلت معهم لمده اربع سنوات بس ما كانت
كافيه بالنسبه لل عرفت انه حان الوقت اني
اطلع من ارامكو لي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
مدينه التناقضات السلفي هناك فوق الجسر
الذهبي هو اجتماع واعمال هناك يبلشوا
المليارات سان فرانسيسكو موطن الانفتاح
وبيت الابداع التكنولوجي
اذكر بدايه اول ما صرت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في قريه كانت حياته جدا بسيطه
صغيره كل بعرف اللي حاول انتقلت الى شكل
اخر من الحياه
العكس جدا سريعه
كل واحد مشغول في نفس ال كل واحد عنده هدف
في الحياه
انت احيانا نعيش على بيت الفتره طويله
علشان اقدر احسب مداخيل واعرف كيف تعيش
اول ما وصلت على الكمالي انه مختلف جدا عن
اي مدينه تمتلك شركات كبيره تحصل الكوبي
وهنا عرفت انه لازم يكون مختلف على الجميع
وتكون جزء من شركه ناس تطورت حاليا وعرفت
انه عليهم السوريه كبيره
ينفع فيها الامه العربيه
انت على
اشتغل على الدعم في هجوم العلوم دور مشعل
مشروعه العربي
لتسليم تنقل الحجاج بين الاماكن المقدسه
في مكه المكرمه وجوارها
[موسيقى]
مساحات لا نهايات لكن بس في جزء بسيط ان
شاء الله نقدر نحصل على يحتاج ان شاء الله
دعوات كمان بدنا نعرف مش عم الوقت وين من
يوم ما جيت سنه ا عرفنا رجل عنيد
عناد ومثابره هذه اللي بتوصل الى النهايه
وان شاء الله الاول اللي قدمتها مشعل
الملايين راح يخدم ابوي وامي راح يقدم
اخواني راح يخدمنا ان شاء الله مستقبلا
والله
المشاهدين
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله كلنا نعرف بسام الفائز
بالموسم الاول الذي وزنا حياته على متن
ابتكاره في نجوم العلوم تجاره تدخل
الاسواق العالميه كما استمع اخرين من ص
التلاقي لعشاق التكنولوجيا اهلا وسهلا
دائما اليوم قاعدين نشوف انه هو يعمل على
نوع جديد من الاختراعات والابتكارات اه
كيف انت تشوفها من من وجهه نظرك اه صراحه
انا بعتبر
انه وصل لهون
معناتها انه اه بيكون موجودين معنا اه
واحد يقدر يوصل لها المرحله معيارين
اساسيين لازم يكونوا موجودين في اول شيء
الطابع الانسان اذا كان عنده طابع اه
الشغله الثانيه اكيد الابتكار هلا حاليا
مع التكنولوجيا تطور التكنولوجيا
من البسه صارت شيء اساسي في حياتنا عم
بياثر علينا يوميا وانا اكيد مع التطبيق
طبعا اذا بيتفقوا المكان المناسب
راح تكون تتوقع ان يكون نجم الموسم التاسع
اه صعب عليه اه صراحه يعني
بيتمنى انه يكون اه اكيد الكل بمجرد وصول
لها المرحله الكل فايز اه وما بيهم ي راح
يفوز بالمرتبه الاولى من المرتب الثاني
امام ثلاث مرات الموقف اللي هي اللي راح
بين عن جد ما راح يرجع حسام كيف ما يهم في
ثلاث مائه دولار امريكي ال ال ال الجائزه
الاولى
[ضحك]
فكره
يعيش الان بعيدا عنها يعرف كافه شوارعها
في مكه المكرمه عرف مشعل الصعوبات التي
يمر بها الحجاج ركز اهتمامه على تسهيل
حياتهم بذكر دال سوار الملاحه للحجاج
خلونا نتعرف اكثر على هذا السؤال
سوار الملاحه لتسهيل مناسك الحج
يمكن السوار الحجاج من التدخل مستخدما
تقنيه البلوتوت في مكه المكرمه يشير
السوار الى مكان الاقامه او الى الاتجاهات
المرغوبه بسهوله يحتوي السوار على شاشه
صغيره او البلدي وعلى الشريحه النفس
لتسجيل البيانات الشخصيه لاستخدامها عند
الحالات الطارئه
الزوار صنعه من ماده مطاطيه تمتص الصدمات
وتحفظ الالكترونيات من الماء والغبار
ويخدم حامد اول اسبوعين بدون توقف بعد ان
اعرف مكانك في مكه المكرمه
[تصفيق]
قال الله تعالى بعد اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم
ولله على الناس حج البيت من استطاع اليه
سبيلا صدق الله العظيم كما تعلمون ان
العواقب التي تواجه الحجاج والمعتمرين
كثيره وان الان في امه محمد ان تخرج منتج
عربي مسلم
الرحمان خدمتهم بسام نتشرف برفعه وواجب
على كل مسلم القيام به وفي هذا اليوم
الكبير اود ان اشكر القائمين على هذا
البرنامج الناجح وهما السبب بعد الله بزرع
قدره هذا المنتج لاحكام نجوم العلوم وهي
مشاهدينا الكرام ادعوكم ان تكون جزء من
سوار الحج وانتظموا ايديكم بيدي لاخراج
هذا المنتج خلف اسوار نجوم العلوم وجعل في
مكه المكرمه ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
انا كنت في ان شاء الله المشكله الاخوان
المشاركين مع المشتركون الاربعه قالوا
كلمتهم والمنافسه على اشدها والقرار
النهائي بعد ثوان فاصل ونعود الى حلبه
المواجهه تواصل معنا عبر موقع البرنامج
وصفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيس بوك
انستقرام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نعم
الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المشاهدين عبر التلفزيون مئات الالاف من
المتابعين عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
انتظار النتيجه النهائيه
للتذكير المجموعه
خمسين بالمائه من النتيجه
الثانيه
المشاهدين
يتنافسون على اللقب الان من
اعضاء لجنه التحكيم
واحد
شكرا ل اعضاء لجنه التحكيم انتهى التصويت
ونصف النتيجه اصبحت جاهزه
اذا حسب تصويت اعضاء لجنه التحكيم اي نصف
النتيجه ذهب المركز الاول لفئات
[موسيقى]
المركز الثاني اللي احنا الكبير
المركز الثالث
محمد الجفيري
اما المركز الرابع فذهب الى مشاكل تذكر
دائما ان التصويت خلال خبرتنا في المواسم
السابقه كان يقلب الموازين
على عقب فهل ستستمر هذه الظاهره
سيستمر في المركز الاول كلكم جديته
واجتهدوا نبيل انا اعتقد المركز الاول ولا
راح تنزل او الرابع مشعل هذا التصويت
سيرفع امس يخرج محمد ان تدين الان
اللي راح تبقى على ما انت عليه ولا راح
ترجع الى المركز الرابع
من كل جانب كانت اقول لكم بعد كل كلمه لكم
وكل تقرير لكن اقول لكم كل التوفيق الى
الان مازالت مصره على كل التوفيق وان تم
فعلا وقال واحمد ومشعل ومحمد يستحقون
اللقب لكن قواعد اللعبه تقول انه واحد فقط
راح يحصل على اللقب وجائزه مائه دولار
امريكي
[موسيقى]
العزيز
بعد اضافه تصويت الجمهور
الى تقييم لجنه التحكيم
صاحب المركز الاول
[موسيقى]
ام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المركز الثالث
من السعوديه
اما المركز الرابع في محافظه الانبار الف
مبروك المركز الاول من التطبيق
اذن دينا الكرام
الى نهايه
الان بانتظار ان شاء الله والموعد راح
يكون على الموسم العاشر راح ينطلق قريبا
مع المزيد بالابتكار والابداع
اما الان استودعكم الله
المرور
ام
[موسيقى]